there he is right-hander chris flex and
that's who the astros have in their
sights tonight
he will be making his 19th start it's
done pretty good on the season nine and
four that three
three five era is good for eighth in the
american league he is not a guy that is
going to go out there and strike a lot
of hitters out only
66 strikeouts in 104 and two-thirds
innings pitched
and the batters are hitting 265 against
flexon
jose altuve digs in for the first at bat
of the night
hands over the head flexing z02 and
altuve a dribbler
left side of the mount flexon can't grab
it on the bare hand and altuve is at
first base
that'll be ruled a base hit flexon knew
he had to bare hand that to have a shot
he was hopping mad
literally after he didn't grab that
cleanly
here's michael brantley who picked up
his 13th three-hit game of the season
now the 2-2 on the way in a swing and a
miss strike three
flexon strikes out michael brantley one
of the toughest to strike out
so one on and one away for the astros
here on the top of the first inning
looked like he pulled a string on him a
little bit
he did that'll bring out first baseman
julie guriel
julie hits it hard in the left field
that'll be a base hit
the astros a couple of base hits here in
the first city against flexon yulia
another two-strike hit he leads all the
baseball
in two-strike batting average alvarez an
rbi single in the first inning yesterday
two on one out no score in the top of
the first
2-0 pitch drill deep right field air
you're done
crushes a pitch to right a three-run
home run
and the astros jump out early just like
last night
you knew that was a home run as soon as
it left jordan's bat
his 19th of the season and for the
second straight night the astros put up
a crooked number in the first
inning oh two and that's hit off the
hands bloop first base side france makes
the catch
rushing in the foul territory just in
front of the coaches box
as france showing some wheels to get to
that baseball caught at waist high to
win the inning
lance mccullers jr on the mound making
his 17th start
the numbers for him this season are
outstanding seven and two with that 3.04
era 107 strikeouts
and how about that opponent batting
average at 195.
cullers doesn't waste any time delivery
swinging a line drive fair down the left
field line
with an extra base in heading for second
up for the ball alvarez the throw to
second head first slide he's safe at
second
jp going after the second pitch from
lance mccullars a line drive
double the other way just fair down the
left field line and alvarez got to that
ball quickly made it a close play at
second cammy
haniger has faced lance mcculler's
junior more than anybody else in this
lineup he's two for 12 with six
strikeouts against lance
got it on hannigard a ground ball at a
third we'll keep the runner in second
good to see you let miss diaz out there
again
he makes the strong throw for the first
out seeger hit a screaming three-run
home run last night
high towering fly ball this is
back out of the warning track and it's
gone
up to the penthouse and over the wall
seeger's ninth career 20 homer
season holy smokes it comes with jp
aboard and it's now the astros 3.
the mariners 2 and early in the game the
mariners and the crowd
right in this game right in it and kyle
seeger provided the punch
he can't believe it ball hit to right
field
back goes tucker makes the catch in
front of the warning track for the final
out
of the inning mariners get two back they
do so on a kyle seeger home run his 20th
of the year is 3-2 houston
3-2 top of the third houston on top of
the mariners 2-2 degree l
off his fist kick save by flexing
recovers coming toward the line
throws off balance and time to get him
gutsy play by chris flexon
he went for the kick save and it worked
and he kicked it
almost foul as he had to come towards
the line and then recovered he kept his
feet this time and threw him out
good play if the seattle kraken needs a
backup to the backup goalie they've got
one there and chris flexo that was a
nice you're right kicks it stuck that
foot out there knocked it down he was
able to hurry go get it
that ball shot the other way that's a
fair ball down the right field line
correa on the move to third he will be
held up there led miss diaz with a
double
in his second at-bat back off the
injured list now miles straw would try
and drive in carlos he flyed out to
right
his first time up straw gets into one
deep center field all the way back
kelnick this ball will be down for a two
rbi
base head straw into second base a big
turn
he'll hold up with a two rbi double it's
five
two astros kellnick was playing shallow
against straw as
most center fielders tend to do and he
got burned there
the astros lead once again by three runs
now martin maldonado will bat
baldi hits it hard straw wasn't sure if
that would be caught
he still might score with his speed he's
being waved around the throw won't be
made
pile straw gets home on that single by
maldonado to make it a six to two game
speed kills that's just trusting the
pure
speed of number three pitch to altuve
breaking ball and that smoke down the
left field line that's a base hit and
that's going to roll all the way to the
wall
maldonado chugging for third he'll be
stopped at third and altuve goes to
second
as that is now four straight hits for
the astros three of them doubles
that one gets away maldonado will come
down the line he'll score
head first slide by maldi yes
seven at two houston has made santiago
three times he has a single and a double
two for three
yes hits it on the ground base hit
through the hall between third and short
that will score jordan alvarez
unless miss diaz with an rbi in his
first game back
since june 5th and the astros now lead
this game
eight to two three and two alvarez
getting ready to take off at first
three two pitch here's hector pit swang
on dribbler right in front of the mount
hector jumps on it
goes to tag the runner coming home from
third and he is out for running out of
the baseline so hector
had forward momentum took advantage of
goriel being on the move
moving it works out hey now this could
be brewing
this could be interesting and you're
right this is what the mariners did last
night they had a lot of great at bats
bunched up before the big big hits
one oh to kill nick pitch swung on up
the middle face hit
here comes france rolling around raleigh
he's going to score without a throw
two run single jarrett kelvik and the
mariners here they come again
they want two swag and a mess got him on
the hook
long angrily flings his back to the on
deck circle
to the surprise of jp crawford as long
showing frustration after striking out
of the big spot
damn the 0-1 pitch swung on line drive
left center field kellett got on the run
dives and he makes the catch
the throw to second base and time to
double up maldonado
holy smokes what a great catch by the
kid
kelly got in left center field diving
through the air with the greatest of
ease
and here is third baseman oled miss diaz
the 1-2
swinging a liner right back in weber
reaches down and he makes the catch
kneecap high
holy smokes you talk about quick
reflexes and a great reaction
and the mariners have the lead off man
on and here is abraham toro pinch
hitting for dylan moore
and making his mariners debut
i fly right field
and at the wall
and it's over hey welcome to town
it's a two-run game the meriters are
still alive
mariners are down to their final out
on the ground guerrilla gets it to
presley in time
and that will do it as the astros hold
on to win eight 8-6